hey you guys are packing sunscreen right
remember this is their summer no I did
I'm trying to get Beyonce dogs on this
straight danger don't worry dude I got
the self tanner it's good to Linda Hogan
endorses it hey has anybody seen my
Tevas I really need my Tevas hey fellas
please remember I got us dinner
reservations Thanksgiving dinner at
pastafari so pack a fancy outfit I've
got a blazer no shirt that's what I'm
thinking but they're kind of GQ
shouldn't should the tie match my
nipples haha guys I found my penis just
so you know I'm really excited and my
11-month dry spell but we're definitely
gonna be seeing each other but Nick and
humping stuff I just hope we're ready
for that oh yeah
buddies ago Blake Stern is ready to get
his knob gobble all right let's get
weird let's get weird okay everyone has
their plane ticket right yeah I thought
we were chaining let's get weird get to
go bathing suits check I will not be
wearing a bathing suit so no and
passports yo yeah
[Music]